candid
truth what is up everybody thank you for
joining us at candid truth we're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it this is going to
be a little bit of a different show
because I have a proposition for you in
this show first off I want to give a
little shout out to our supporters
because we cannot do this without you
guys and I just want to say thank you
Mary Ellen thank you Troy trilion thank
you sh sh serona Sullivan heg Torres
Daryl
Stewart um Peter
Williams Cindy gml Collins carbon
Cassidy
opris um man there's so many on here
thank you guys so much and especially a
a shout out
to suku suku and NOA
I probably butchered those names there's
a lot more on there but those are some
people who have really keep helped keep
this thing going my wife and I stepped
away from a steady paycheck to make this
channel happen to make candid truth or
reality because God told us I want you
to start your own Ministry and and here
it is we stepped out in faith and God
has provided each month and it's just
been
amazing but this is something something
that's been on my heart I was deceived
growing up if you guys don't know my
testimony it's on my channel it's on a
lot of different channels I go Church to
church sharing my testimony because I
was raised in church my parents did the
best they could to teach me the truth
and I accepted Christ at about nine
years old but then I started to be
seduced by the media MTV especially MTV
drew me in when I saw spring break and
everybody's in bikinis and they're
getting drunk and hooking up and there's
a band playing on stage and it looked
fun the violent video games were fun The
Simpsons were fun Beavis and Butthead
all this stuff drew me in and I started
asking tough questions I didn't want to
miss out on the fun and so I thought is
Christianity just about everything
that's fun is evil so I started asking
really tough questions like uh this is
at like 12 years old asking the youth
pastor how come God said Thou shalt not
kill and yet he murdered the entire
world in a flood and I would get answers
like some things we just won't know till
we get to heaven to me that was a copout
I thought these Christians they don't
know anything they're ignorant if it's e
if it's you know if we don't understand
it it must be evil or of of the devil
and so I started looking elsewhere at
age 12 I I accepted Christ at nine by
age 12 I was completely checked out of
the church went into the Witchcraft
world and started looking into casting
spells and playing Ouija boards and
Tarot cards and trying to ghost hun out
in graveyards and thank God my mom never
stopped praying for me because God
protected me through so much stuff and
by age
21 I kind of hit a rock bottom and
realized God's real I started seeking
him and it was a slow growth but by that
was 20 2005 but by 2013 I I got full
surrender fully surrender to God and he
set me free from addictions put me in
Ministry and the rest is history here we
are now something that happened to me
the deception that happened to me was I
was obsessed with ghosts and aliens at
in elementary school second grade I was
checking out books in the library on
ghost and Aliens like pictures of what
is that ghostly thing in the hallway
what is that glowing light in the sky
and I believed it I was like these are
photographs this isn't Goosebumps this
isn't sci-fi
stuff and that was something that the
church didn't really have good answers
for
either I I understand that back in the
90s 93 94 when all this was going on
when I was intrigued with this stuff
there wasn't a lot of resources out
there there wasn't a lot of good
information out there it was kind of a
fringy topic that you weren't going to
hear talked about from the pulpit I get
it but now there's no excuse for the
church not to talk about this when the
military and the government are having
Congressional hearings and they're
saying yes UFOs are real we've seen them
every day for years and by the way we're
communicating with nonhuman
intelligences and have been since the
1930s it's time for the church to start
talking about it I'm sick of us like
being afraid to talk about controversial
topics things that need to be discussed
this is why the youth is leaving the
church because they're not getting
answers from the church guess who is
talking about this subject the new age
world so how many youth young people
that have legitimate questions what is
this what is this I keep hearing about
UFOs and alien the news the military is
saying they're real what do you say I
don't believe that stuff you don't
believe that stuff you don't you can't
get by with that anymore you can't just
say oh I don't believe in that stuff
it's happening it's here and we're about
to enter into the year 2025
this is a big deal we we've just been in
a huge left swing politically far left
where everything we're lawlessness
abounds no no genders 68 genders and
gender fluid and uh ages of preference
and there's just anything goes
lawlessness defund the police all this
but now we're swinging far right and the
project 2025 the farri conservatives
have a a manifest that says they want
the next right-wing president which they
hoped would be Trump and it is they are
giving him the the freedom to be like a
a religious dictator basically he can
enact any religious law and guess what
there's a there's a such thing as
separation of church and state we need
that otherwise we go back to the
Medieval ages we get we go back to papal
Rome where they're torching you at the
stake if you don't worship a certain way
this is exactly how the mark of the
beast is going to come in it's order out
of chaos we're getting to a point where
there's so much chaos that the stage is
being set for Satan to appear as Christ
and say I'm here to fix all your
problems I can get rid of the pandemic I
can get rid of climate change I can cure
all these cancer diseases that we have
now because of all the genetic
genetically modified foods and the
chemicals in our air and water and all
this
stuff Satan can get rid of those things
portraying to be Christ and who are we
Christians who know that this is a
deception to say this is the devil this
isn't Jesus and people are going to say
are you crazy he's healing people lock
these people up they're a discordant
note in this perfect peace and safety
that we have so as a Christian you will
be labeled a bigot a conspiracy theorist
a hater for knowing the truth now all
this to
say the church is isn't speaking up and
children the youth have questions and I
want children to know the truth and I
have a testimony to
share and I'm not going to read it it's
kind of lengthy but a woman reached out
to me and she donated to our ministry
and she donated on behalf of her
daughter she said my daughter is 9 years
old but when she was six she saw your
documentary that you put on Little Light
Studios if you guys haven't seen it it's
called disclosed deceiving the world
disclosed a UFO documentary on Little
Light Studios it's 35 minutes long very
sharable needs to get out there her
daughter at 6 years old watched that had
her eyes opened it was sharing it with
everyone at her school and watched it
more times than her mom could count it
was her daughter's favorite
documentary the day after they watched
that documentary her brother her
non-believing brother her atheist
brother calls this lady and says will
you pray for our son his son was three
years old this is her non-believing
brother and his non-believing wife they
needed prayer this woman drove over to
their house to find out what was going
on and found out from the kid from the
three-year-old kid that he was having
encounters every night that three beings
were entering into his room coming
through the the walls grabbing him by
the ankles in the middle of the night
and dragging him off of his bed and
pulling him towards the wall to try and
pull him through the wall this
three-year-old kid was experiencing this
every night for I don't know how long
and this woman prayed and fasted the kid
said that he was seeing these beings
that were pale skin piercing blue eyes
and blonde hair and immediately she got
taken back to the documentary that I met
made the night
before she saw it the night before and
she's like it was God's perfect timing
that I saw that documentary because in
that documentary you mentioned that
there's the Grays the reptilians and the
blondes and this kid was seeing these
blondes and her and her daughter looked
at each other at the same time and knew
exactly what this was and because they
knew that this was a demonic deception
because of that documentary because of
information coming out they knew how to
fight this spiritual warfare this is
spiritual warfare and the church is
afraid to talk about it the church is
failing and inadvertently leading people
astray into the new age world and other
places that are talking about this
subject I praise God that he opened my
eyes when he did because I was
completely deceived even as a Christian
I thought that UFOs LED Moses out of the
Wilderness that God created this vast
universe and well he must have created
other life out there and God likes to
send agents to do his bidding and so God
told these aliens hey go go lead Moses
out of the Wilderness and Ezekiel Saw a
wheel within a wheel he was seeing a
UFO I was so deceived because there
wasn't good information out there now
there is and it's time for the church to
speak up and I have I praise God that I
have had the honor of sharing this
presentation I'm about to share with you
guys at many different churches around
the us twice in Bolivia where it was
translated nine different languages once
in Guatemala with the biggest audience
I've ever spoken
to and we're not it's still not enough
there's many churches that have said
that they don't want to talk about it
there's been a really
large Christian television network that
says we will not talk about this because
it sounds too
conspiratorial how how is this a
conspiracy Theory when they're on the
news telling us that these things are
real and we're not going to address it
if the military came on the news and
said you know what we we talk to dead
people every day or we talk to angels
every day we'd be in the Pulpit the next
day talking about it this is
spiritualism in the last days this is
what we knew was coming this is prophecy
but because Satan has disguised himself
into this alien form we are afraid to
talk about it now so to come combat
that I want to put out a book that I
helped produce me and a friend
brainstormed and came up with a story
that would be great for kids we hired a
an author to write it and so and then I
I had another friend who came up with uh
something in the back how to memorize
scripture and like a board game and
trivia and all this stuff to try and
solidify these IDE make sure that the
kid is getting the concept of the story
the book is right
here and it's it's you would not believe
it this has been two years in the making
and Satan does not want this book to
come out it is not even titled this
anymore I printed this I had this
printed through a company and it cost me
like $24 for this one
prototype but I want to tell you about
it it's now called aby's strange dreams
so this book is currently available on
Amazon uh but there's an issue on Amazon
Amazon doesn't like to do wide format
books so they don't like this they they
do books portrait mode so this is the
size I want the book to be big and
colorful this is the size that I had to
get for Amazon you see how small that is
this is just an example there's a big
difference there
so I want to print this myself and I
want to make it free I want to make this
re a free resource that anyone can give
to their children their grandchildren
their nieces their
nephews um because right now on Amazon
it's
$9.99 I don't care about profits I don't
want anything from this book I want the
message to reach the world I want the
youth to not be deceived when something
big is coming I forgot to mention this
whole project 2025 thing is is only half
of the puzzle the occult world if you
know who Alice Bailey is she has written
something that the UN has adopted and
she was a channeling writer she she
channels and she said that in 2025 now
she wrote this back in like the 1800s or
the early 1900s she said in
2025 we would be reaching the age of
Aquarius and that Spirits were going to
manifest that demon Spirits are going to
manifest so you know this is an occult
Source but I think
it's I think it's something that we
should be prepared for that we are
seeing on the news like crazy that UF
are real that videos are popping up
every where what is it I don't know this
lady said that in 2025 demons are going
to manifest we have a someone in place
right now who can be a religious dict
Ator and can enact this thing so before
I get into the presentation I want you
guys to get a sneak peek of this book
it's going to cost
$3,000 to print a th000 that's less than
$2 it it's to to print these it's like
$2,800 but there's going to be shipping
and taxes and all that kind of stuff so
this is deceiving the world this is the
presentation we are coming into 2025 I
think something is going to happen I
think it's going to be something that
none of us have ever experienced in our
lives we know that in ancient Egypt
these people worshiped beings from the
Stars they were Heathen heathens that
worshiped beings from the Stars this is
just we're going into a new cycle Satan
is up to his old tricks he appeared as
raw and Horus and Isis and all these
things in the past and in our time right
now the final deception is going to be
this alien
deception we know that the only thing
coming to Earth that's going to be a
threat is Christ and All His angels when
he comes at his second coming if you are
not on his side and be caught up to meet
him in the air you will be destroyed by
the brightness of his coming that's a
threat to the world not to us if you're
not on the right side and when you read
Revelation it says that Satan is going
to round up the militaries of the world
to battle to to The Great Battle of the
day of God
Almighty that's what's coming and what I
believe is that Satan is
masquerading as these alien visitors who
are going to come and perform lying
signs and wonders and when they gain our
trust they're going to say there's an
evil alien Invader coming to take over
your Earth and if you don't side with us
in this war you'll never win and
Humanity will side with demons in a
battle against Christ and it's all a GI
deception let's get into this I want you
guys to see because this was me as a
teenager in high school fresh out of
high school I was deceived by the world
and this is where it led me the
9-year-old boy that accepted Christ
alone in a car by himself one day and my
parents were so moved by it and so
excited that their son accepted Christ
turned into this because the church
didn't have the answers this is where it
leads when the church
doesn't teach the
truth I thank God that he never gave up
on me he kept coming after me he never
gave up on me he's the Hound of
heaven so that's where it comes to this
book aby's strange dreams I'm going to
play it's a three minute video of the
book A book reading and you guys can see
every page and hear it read and and see
this has never been done before to my
understanding there's never been a
children's spiritual warfare book this
book is for toddler to 10 years old it
could be forer but I just think it's a
it's a lower reading level but I want to
make more things I want to make more
free resources candid truth wants to put
out literature little hand-sized pieces
of literature that tell you why you
shouldn't go see the movie Wicked what
are
UFOs lots of free resources but we need
Don to make it happen because it cost a
lot of money to print these things and
when we get them printed we're shipping
them out for free so that we can get
this message out to the world so we can
go home so Jesus can
come all right Abby strange dreams check
it out Abby's strange dreams authored
and narrated by Athena
Sorenson I woke up in the night and
didn't know what to feel I had a strange
dream that felt so very
real I looked outside my window and
there up in the sky I seen a bunch of
spaceships with aliens
inside One landed on my roof I heard the
engine blast is he coming in my room my
heart was beating
fast he jumped in through my window with
a gift in his hands he said hello my
friend I've traveled From A Distant land
land he told me not to listen if my
parents say he's bad you and I will be
best friends I'll be here when you're
sad I had another dream last night much
different than the last I barely fell
asleep when it happened oh so
fast I looked and seen an angel standing
by my bed he sat down right beside me
and this is what he said you're loved
ones that have passed away are actually
still here you can talk to them anytime
no need to worry or have
fear my third dream was very odd I
wonder what it meant it seemed to last
for hours and this is how it went a
dragon came out from my bed he gave me
quite a fright he slithered along my
floor then wrapped me up so tight
he looked me in the eyes and said do not
be afraid don't bother trying to pray
for help cuz I will keep you
safe we played games through the night
until the sun came up I didn't want it
all to end he was so much
fun I listened to the dragon though I
knew it wasn't right I hid it from my
parents and stopped praying at
night bad things begin toen happened my
life was falling apart my dog got sick I
often cried and felt so empty in my
heart I finally told my mom about all
the dreams I had she said my dear you
need to pray God will help you not feel
sad she handed me her Bible turned to
Ephesians 6 I read about God's armor and
how it protects from Satan's tricks I
bowed my head and began to pray cover me
with your
armor all my sadness went away now I'm
feeling so much
stronger now that God opened my eyes I
could see through all their lies they
were devils in
Disguise I told them leave in the name
of Jesus
Christ I choose to wear God's armor
every single day and every night before
I sleep I get on my knees and pray
[Music]
he all right so that is it guys that is
the book it's a short read it's for
children the children of the future this
is who Satan's after and so how are they
going to know they got questions the
church isn't talking about it movies are
talking about it movies are saying
aliens are your friend he's ET hey my
pet dragon they are bombarded with media
telling them that monsters are your
friend Elmo Cookie Monster vampire like
the count you realize that Sesame Street
are monsters they've been propagating
this for years and years and years I'm
not just making that up Elmo calls
himself a Monster Cookie Monster there's
aliens and everything in that show too
this has been priming children for years
Yo Gaba Gaba these monsters that are
your friends Dragons monsters
aliens
vampires and they're not they're going
to be taken off guard because Satan he's
been coming through
mythology aliens all this stuff for
years and years we need to have the
truth we have the truth we need to share
the truth we need to present the truth
like I said I don't know if there is a
book out there like this so far the book
as actually
continues and it has the full armor of
God so that children can know what it is
it's the helmet of salvation the
breastplate of righteousness sword of
the spirit Shield of Faith belt of Truth
boots of peace they can see it visually
they can learn it and this is this is a
note for the parents to read to the kids
and make sure they got the thing
discernment discernment what is
discernment discernment means to use our
best judgment God doesn't want us to be
deceived deceived or tricked by anyone
or anything sometimes people may pretend
to be your friend to try and trick you
into trusting them so that they can hurt
you if any grownup comes to you when
your parents aren't around and wants to
give you a gift or ask you to come with
them so they can show you something
really cool never go until you ask your
parents first the Bible which is the
sword of the spirit teaches us how to
not be tricked by Satan and his Fallen
Angels the in the Book of Genesis Satan
pretended to be a wise talking Serpent
and he was able to trick Eve into
disobeying God Eve lived in a perfect
world and was very smart how much easier
would it be for Satan to trick Us by
transforming himself into a beautiful
angel of Light an alien or even a dead
loved one a lot of movies games and TV
shows have stories where creatures from
other worlds are friendly but the Bible
teaches us that we must test every
Spirit if an unusual being visits you
and tells you to trust them what should
you do put on the whole armor of God
pray ask Jesus to send them away and he
will to find out what the Bible teaches
us about not to find out what the Bible
teaches us about not allowing the Devil
to trick us read first John 4th uh 1
through3 2 Corinthians 11:1 13-15 Isa
Isaiah 816-201-6480
[Music]
stand against the Ws of the
devil and then I don't know the rest but
you get the idea this is teaching
children scripture the most important
thing one can do if you guys want to
donate to this there's a link in the
description right now and there's links
in the
chat um there this is the board game
this is all inside the book you you take
like a small toy or a penny or whatever
you use that as your game piece you roll
a die whatever number it lands on
there's questions that the parent can
ask you about the book like why do you
think the alien say why do you think the
alien says this about grown-ups you know
let the children use their discernment
and their critical thinking skills if
they land on one of these um pieces of
armor they get to do like a a challenge
like a a miname basically so this is all
teaching children and then at the end it
says say thank you so much for your for
your love of the truth this message is
vital for young people today who are
growing up in a world where the military
is on the news daily telling us that
aliens are among us you would not
believe how many spiritual attacks
slowed down the production of this book
Satan definitely does not want the his
final deception exposed please share
this book and this message far and wide
before it's too late this has been a
candid truth book check out these Eye
openening YouTube channels Little Light
Studios candid truth and strange
normal it's true you would not believe
how
much has tried to slow this book down
two years in the making two
years and and there was drama the first
time with an author we had to change
authors it's just been insane you would
not believe how many spiritual attacks
come do you almost give up and then
you're like no I'm going to put this
thing on Amazon and then even put trying
to get it on Amazon was so difficult it
took two
days and and then now it's not even the
right size so we need your help if you
guys see the value in this then please
click the link in the description go to
the Donate I know it's an unusual thing
it's not a GoFundMe this is called zy
zhy is a free donation thing make sure
you it's going to say do you want to tip
the the thing will be checked
automatically that's how they that's how
they get their money they get they
basically trick people into giving a tip
to their website uncheck that box so
that your whole donation can go to this
book when we get $3,000 this book is
getting printed and they're going to be
distrib a thousand of them distributed
for free and if there's more than that
that comes in I'll print more the more
you the more you purchase the lower the
price so I want to pray before we start
because this is a a huge
topic Lord Father in Heaven I just thank
you so much for your truth I thank you
for your word that we do not have to be
deceived in these last days we are
coming into crazy times a time like we
have never seen before millions of
people are going to be deceived millions
of people are going to be taken over by
this overwhelming unexpected surprise
Lord help us to be ready for what's
coming help us to not fall for our
senses to to fall for the things that we
see with our eyes but to stand firmly on
what your word has told us we understand
prophecy and all these things that are
coming and we know that when you come we
will be caught up to meet you in the air
you're not going to be on earth walking
around but Satan is going to manifest
pretending to be you before that happens
help us to not fall into that deception
and help us to get others ready as well
Lord I'm asking a big impossible prayer
you said said I have not because I ask
not I'm praying that this fundraiser
will meet its goal by the end of this
presentation Lord I Thank you so much
for everybody that's here I pray that
this will be an eye openening
presentation I can't wait to get this
book out into the hands of many many
children who have questions in Jesus
name amen so why are we talking about
this topic that seems kind of fringey
you know first Peter 3:15 says but
sanctify the Lord God in your hearts and
be ready always to give an
answer be ready always to give an answer
to every man that askthe a reason of the
hope that is in you with meekness and
fear so we need to be ready to give an
answer we you know there's going to be a
lot of tough questions that are coming
up we live in a day and age where people
have tough questions we have to be ready
to have an answer this is what caused me
to go astray not having answers 2
Thessalonians 2:3 says let no man
deceive you by any means for that day
shall not come except there come a
falling away first what day the day of
Christ's return they said what will be
the sign of your coming he said let no
man deceive you the first response is
about deception let no man deceive you
except there come a falling away first
has there been a falling away oh yeah a
falling away like I've never seen in my
life where people are entertaining
themselves with wickedness including a
movie called wicked where people are
just
embracing the these perverted Lifestyles
we are in a falling away and we are
about to be in a a big
deception now the spirit expressively
says in the latter times some will
depart from the faith you can't depart
from something you never had this idea
of once saved always saved is not
biblical many will depart from the faith
why because they're giving heed to
deceiving spirits and doctrines of
demons speaking lies and hypocrisies
having their own conscience seared with
a hot so they had a conscience once they
grew up knowing the truth but they're
going to see something so
deceptive
so spiritual and lying wonders and
demons that they're going to fall from
the faith because of what they see in
the latter times I believe we're there
Matthew 10:26 says therefore do not fear
them for there is nothing covered that
will not be revealed and hidden that
will not be known that's the point of
this presentation to unveil the things
that are hidden and the secrets the
conspiracies that are going on in the
world the Bible has the answers God says
nothing that is covered will not be
revealed Revelation 12:9 says and the
dragon was cast out that old serpent
called the devil and Satan which
deceives the whole world we're talking
about a worldwide deception not just the
atheists not just the worldly people but
Christians are included included in the
whole world right he was cast out into
the Earth and his angels were cast out
with him something big is coming
Revelation 13313 through 14 says and he
doeth great wonders so that he maketh
Fire come down from heaven on the earth
and the sight of men and deceiveth them
that dwell on the Earth by the means of
those Miracles why are people falling
from the faith because of deceiving
Miracles that are going to be deceived
that are going to happen in the sight of
men
Matthew
24:24 for there shall arise false Christ
false prophets and show great signs and
wonders in so much that if it were
possible they shall deceive the very
elect I think this word elect is smaller
than we give it credit for it's not just
oh I'm a Christian I'm a part of the
elect I don't think that's how it works
I think it's a Remnant who keep the
Commandments of God and follow the lamb
wherever he goes and pick up their cross
daily and die to the list of the Flesh
and endure to the end these are things
describing a small group of Christians
today there's not a lot of Christians
that do those things but these they're
going to be false christs and false
prophets it doesn't say that they're
even human I believe these could be
these deceptive demons that are working
miracles and showing signs and wonders
so Miracle working demons signs and
wonders and have no fellowship with the
unfruitful works of darkness but rather
expose them that's the point of this
present ation to expose the unfruitful
works of darkness now this is an older
presentation I put this thing together
like three years ago maybe longer let's
see
2021 so this is kind of old news if you
keep up with the news right now let me
let me uh switch and show you guys
what's going on right now because in the
news currently at this moment if you
search the news for UAP that's the new
term for UFOs one day ago Pilots report
mysterious UFO
sighting uh drones mysterious drones
what are these drones Pilots report
mysterious lights the mysterious drone
swarm swarm over British so it's it's
not just happening in New Jersey but in
the the British the US government must
come clean about UFOs says the hill
mysterious objects in the sky what are
they 22 hours ago Pilots told to
maneuver around Oregon UFO and leaked
cabin audio three days ago NPR news
experts testified before lawmakers that
the US is running secret UAP programs
this is what's happening right now USA
Today a month ago Congress heard more
testimony about UFOs here are the
biggest Revelations so this is not
something that's going away this is here
thank you so much guys we already got
$75 in the donation I think I have to
click update on the site for you guys to
see it but down below you can see 75 I
don't know who gave it I see actually it
was a couple donations praise God thank
you guys so much we're going to do it
we're going to get this book out to the
world all right
so this article this uh NBC news said us
intelligence agencies are expected to
deliver a report on unid unidentified
aerial phenomenon to Congress next month
this is 2021 guys when this was this was
2021 they're having Congressional
meetings all the time now and every time
it's the same they get up there they say
yeah we see strange things and the
people in the the podiums they're like
okay is it is it alien they're like we
don't know and they're just like well
what else do you know well we talk to
them they're non-human intelligences
we're
talking just think about that
nonhuman
intelligences that's demons they're
talking to Demons without saying they're
talking to Demons this is crazy all
right signs of a supernatural
character this is crazy how in-depth
this is because it says fearful sights
of a and Great Signs shall there be from
heaven so we're going to see fearful
sights in the heavens what is that we're
already seeing some fearful sights in
the heavens right when people see this
they're like oh my goodness what is that
I don't
know uh testimonies to ministers and
gospel workers it says as we near the
close of time there will be a greater
and still greater external parade of
heathen power Heathen deities will will
manifest their signal power and will
exhibit themselves before the cities of
the world and this delineation has
already begun to be fulfilled do you see
it guys Heathen deities are going to
manifest and parade themselves over the
cities of the world is that happening
right now yes just watch the news it's
all over people are showing on their
phones lights in the
skies Heathen deities heathens used to
worship being from the Stars Sirius
Orion raw all these beings from the
Stars this is Anubis um the
anunaki Satan is up to his old tricks
again Egyptian old
tricks watch this clip just to prove
that this is happening like this is not
just some Fringe thing this was 2021
when all these clips were grabbed check
this
out frankly there are a lot more
sightings than have been made public um
movements that uh that are hard to
replicate that we don't have the
technology for we don't have it they
don't have it the question is who has it
who's operating these vehicles the
information is very compelling it's it's
real yeah okay it's real are they from
another planet if it's not ours and it's
not theirs well then it's it's someone
or something else I can't wait for this
report to come out there is no longer
any doubt unidentified flying objects
are re this one was seen by now retired
Navy pilot Alex Dietrich in her F-18 off
the coast of California UFO sightings in
New York have nearly doubled since the
pandemic began and we are getting new
video from the Navy showing
pyramid-shaped objects flying in the sky
these cell phone photos taken by a fa8
pilot in March of 2019 show three
different unidentified aircrafts off the
coast of oceanana a Department of
Defense spokesperson said quote I can
confirm that the referenced photo pH and
videos were taken by Navy personnel the
unidentified aerial phenomena task force
has included these incidents in their
ongoing examinations a US intelligence
report on UFOs is expected to be
released very soon the long awaited
Pentagon report on UFOs has finally been
released Friday the US government
released a much anticipated report on
everything it knows about UFOs now the
study released on Friday found only one
of those can be explained just one Lisa
thank you you so much I see your comment
thank you God bless you we're already
over over onethird of the way
there this is a long presentation we're
already over a third of the way to
getting these books out there thank you
guys so much God bless you it's going to
happen God is so good he's our provider
now check this out all that all those
UFO footages they're like only one could
be explained I think that's what she
said I wasn't even paying attention
anymore because I'm just so excited
about what's going on
this is happening is the church not
going to address this I just told you
that there are churches that are afraid
there
are there are Ministries out there that
can reach so many people on the airwaves
and they won't talk about this subject
this is why this is so
important so check this
out uh a recent poll surveyed and this
was when I say recent this was probably
2021 a recent poll surve surveyed
10,417 us adults in light of the release
of a UFO report by Congress made public
last year about 65% of the respondents
said they think there is intelligent
alien life on planets other than Earth
65% now look what it says about three4
or 76% of that 65% of adults under the
age of 30 say intelligent life exists on
other planets versus is 57% of those
that are 50 and older so who are the
ones that are believing that there's
life on other planets the younger people
right the adults under the age of 30
that means every generation this gets
accepted more and more I watched a black
and white video of a guy going on the
street interviewing people and saying do
you believe in aliens and they're like
no that's that's sci-fi stuff that was
I'm guessing if it was black and white
that was probably the 30s the 40s the
50s or something and now here we are 24
and I'm I'm betting nobody doubts that
there's aliens now because now it's on
the news right the news never lies the
News tells the truth right so if the
news is saying it they got to be real
and we're talking about History Channel
and everything all right I'm getting
ahead of myself so this is not just in
the secular world this isn't like
Nickelodeon and MTV and stuff this is
actually getting into the Christian
World check this out it says um
Storyteller Cafe this is a DVD that I
actually bought for my daughter one time
because it uh it's it's like a Christian
Toy Story
basically and as you can tell there's a
little alien in a UFO and he's a good
guy he's your friend in a Christian show
now over here we see elevation eids
elevation is a very well huge very
well-known huge church and it says
Listen to Adventures of the Starke
Keepers and Elevation Church kids
podcast come along for an adventure
filled with mystery laughs and
faith-based
lessons the the mascot is an alien why
because aliens are so cool and trendy
and let's bring them into the church
let's bring the aliens in the
church so ancient astronaut theory if
you haven't heard this Theory before uh
it's been out since I know like the 60s
and 70s they started getting into this
where they were finding these ancient
artifacts and they were saying hey maybe
ancient civiliz ations weren't
neanderthals maybe they're actually
really smart and they were actually
traveling to space because they were
seeing outfits like this that looked
like astronaut outfits now I believe
that people a long time ago were not
neanderthals that's the idea of
evolution see Satan loves the twist the
truth God actually we are devolving God
made Adam and Eve perfect they were
perfect beings that use 100% of their
brain were super intelligent live to be
900 years
old and now we are devolving so you know
we're we're going we're going to be in
the days of
Noah right so I don't disbelieve that
people were really smart and were had
technology and everything I don't know
what kind but think about this for a
second this an interesting thought if
a catastrophic flood happen right now in
our
society and everything was buried under
mud floods and all this stuff under and
we and then people a hundred years from
now or thousands of years they say 5,000
years down the road started Excavating
what would they find technology-wise or
how would they know how technologically
advanced we are right now I'm
communicating with you know a hundred
people or something and later when this
gets published thousands of people will
see it and I'm sitting in my house but
if somebody were to excavate I'm saying
that right right excavate this laptop
and microphone and this phone that's
being used as a
camera that doesn't tell them anything
they're like what is this piece of
plastic oh it's probably like a a
coaster or something you know like they
don't they won't have the technology to
be able to find out what it is like oh
it's not just a it's not just this thing
it actually you can beam yourself to the
whole world that's that's getting out
there I'm sorry what I'm getting at is
we don't know what kind of Technology
the ancient past had because it might be
all digital for all we know maybe
there's a thumb drive maybe there's uh
micro dust or whatever micro computers
out there that we don't even know so I
don't believe that people of the past
were neanderthals I believe they're
smart intelligent and I don't know what
they're doing I don't believe in space
travel though I'll tell you
that
these alien beings these quote unquote
alien beings have been etched in walls
that go way back ancient times so this
is nothing new this isn't like some 80s
propaganda that came out people have
been seeing these things for a long time
so we're building a case here make sure
what I'm going to do in this
presentation is I'm going to show you
every possible angle of this thing are
they visitors from other worlds are they
uh Spiritual Beings what are they what
do the new age think about them what
does the Catholics think about them what
does the atheist think about them so
we're building a case here
okay so these things have been around
for a long time this is not just some
new um 80s
propaganda then there was a show that
was called Ancient Aliens this is what
sucked me in back in 2000 I don't know
2005 or so this show gave me all the
answers I was looking for because the
church wasn't giving me answers and I
was like okay I'm a Christian now I
accepted Christ in 2004 and I was like
um what do I do with this whole alien
thing I believe in aliens because
there's just too much evidence out there
and how does this tie in with the Bible
Well Ancient Aliens started showing you
know this is ancient etchings on walls
and medieval paintings and more walls
and all this and then they show
something like this on the screen and
they said aliens LED Moses out of the
wilderness that's what that Pillar of
Fire was he was following a beam of
light from a
UFO because the Bible does say in Exodus
13:21 and the Lord went before them by
day in a pillar of cloud to lead them
the way and by Night a pillar of fire to
give them light to go by day and night
so I wasn't reading my Bible I didn't
know that that was actually God and I
was like oh wow this is the answer this
is true true you know I'm watching
History Channel this isn't the Sci-Fi
channel this makes sense to
me the pillar of cloud by day could have
been the exhaust
of of a spacecraft of a UFO this is what
I was thinking then I started finding
out that you know what this isn't even
space this isn't just space anyway that
our own military has built these crafts
and test flew them and everything the
Nazis did the US Air Force did and this
is documented that they were building
these flying saucers so now I'm like
wait a minute is this all just like a a
giant conspiracy a big deception that um
the military is actually pretending to
be
aliens I don't
know so how come when we
see a glowing orb in the sky because
that's 90% of the sightings 90% of the
sightings don't say I saw metallic
and bolts and this was definitely a
craft of some sort people are seeing a
glowing ball in the sky and
automatically they're programmed to
think if I see a glowing orb that's a
that's an alien from another world why
because of all the propaganda that's
been coming out our whole lives and
generations before us sci-fi novels
radio shows movies TV shows we've been
programmed when you see something flying
in the sky that's glowing
it's an alien from another planet not
something spiritual I bet a thousand
years ago if somebody saw something like
that in the sky their mind wouldn't go
right to alien flying a spaceship right
they'd probably be thinking more
spiritual but we've been programmed over
the
years check this out this was the United
Nations in
1987 and this is what Ronald Reagan said
in our obsession with antagonisms of the
moment
we often forget how much unites all the
members of
humanity perhaps we need some outside
Universal threat to make us recognize
this common
bound I occasionally think how quickly
our differences worldwide would vanish
if we were facing an alien threat from
outside this
world and yet I ask you is not an alien
force already Among Us so Ronald Reagan
1987 at the United Nations said how
could we unite everybody how could we
bring about a new world order I bet we
could if there was an alien threat so
automatically I get red flags because as
someone that studies prophecy I know
that there's coming a one world order a
One World Government one world religion
and now you got the United Nations all
the nations of the world uniting
together in a meeting where they're
saying how could we unite the world
maybe with an alien threat and so it's
like interesting that uh they're
actually building these crafts maybe
they are preparing to make a false Alien
Invasion and cause everyone to unite
right maybe but then you got to ask well
what about all these ancient etchings
you know this stuff goes way back so
we're building the case here it's like
is it military no it can't just be
military because we got all these
ancient artifacts as well so check this
out because they're openly admitting
when I was into this stuff when I was
looking into this as a a kid and a
teenager man I thought I was like on to
something I was like dude on Fox tonight
they're doing the ancient they're doing
the alien autopsy it's a leak bro and
and I thought man how deceived was I to
think that Fox News could air a leaked
Alien video we know the media is so
controlled nothing nothing gets leaked
out if anyone ever says a whistleblower
or a leaked and they're on Fox News you
already know it's not it's not legit
because nothing is truly leaked or a
whistleblower on controlled mainstream
media that's just the fact and so when I
was seeing the a the the alien
autopsy I thought man I'm onto it like
they're hiding the truth I want to know
the truth stop hiding the truth from me
and then you know I'd see the these
different things like
that um but I think that that's actually
where they're trying to lead us the
powers that be they're purposely leaking
out something here a little
misinformation a little disinformation
to make the people feel empowered so
that the people will say we want to know
the truth stop hiding the truth tell us
the truth and they'll say okay and
that'll be disclosure but instead of the
truth it's going to be a huge deception
because they're not going to come out
and say yeah we're we actually work hand
inand with demons they're going to say
no these are visitors from these are
aliens from another world so check this
out because when I was growing up
everything was blown off as oh it was a
weather balloon it was uh swamp gas but
but check out what they say in this
speaking to fighter pilots who reported
seeing unidentified flying objects every
day every day for at least a couple
years this was extremely abrupt like a
pingpong ball bouncing off a wall the
ability to hover over the water and then
start a vertical climb from basically
zero up towards about 12,000 ft and then
accelerate in less than two seconds and
disappear is something I had never seen
in my life in my position as the ranking
member of terrorism en Counter
Intelligence we need to know what this
is so now they're saying oh yeah every
day I've been seeing this stuff every
day that doesn't coexist you can't say
oh it's all swamp gas and weather
balloons and it's all been explained
away and yep I see them every day and
have been for years so already there's
opposing stories that that can't coexist
so somebody's lying right in December
2019 I think this is
interesting December
2019 there was a US space force December
2019 Trump was in office and they formed
a new branch of military so now we're
defending not just land and sea and the
air but defending space why why in 2019
it's very interesting look at that date
December 20
2019 that's the end of 2019 do you
remember what happened around that time
something big it it shut down our
world the Pentagon has six months to
disclose what it knows about UFOs this
is old remember guys this was in uh 2021
this is military.com it says as part of
the newly passed
covid-19 Regis relief legislation
lawmakers are demanding answers from us
intelligence agencies and the defense
department on the potential existence of
UFOs and other unidentified aerial
phenomenon so things are escalating fast
from 2021 they're like all right we want
to know is there anything and now it's
like every day they're on the news
saying it's real blah blah blah but why
was it wrapped up in this covid-19
relief
legislation this makes no sense but when
did Co happen right after December 20
2019 a US space force so we get a space
force and then immediately after that
they're like we demand to know
everything you know about
UFOs interesting I don't think that's a
coincidence in this article it says that
this thing was
5,593 page bill
uh and in there it says that they have
to disclose everything they know about
UFOs who read this bill who read 5,593
pages nobody they just signed this thing
and this is all planned this was all
part of the chess game that we are a
part of we don't want to be a part of it
but we're in this spiritual war this
prophecy that's unrolling out so this
was all
orchestrated us space force covid relief
plan thing and remember the first clip
said there's been double the sighting
since the covid happened that's what
they said so non-human nonhuman entities
what are these things check out this
clip the materials that these craft are
made of are clearly not of this Earth
yeah they're sophisticatedly engineered
um certainly not by humans so he's just
saying right there these are not
human how does he know this is supposed
to be a whistleblower a whistleblower on
mainstream media news remember there's
no such thing as a whistleblower on
mainstream Media news I have to say
thank you guys so much
$1,625 we're over halfway there we are
over halfway to getting a thousand a
thousand of these books printed this
size for children to know the truth
about testing the spirits putting on the
full armor of God and what to expect in
this crazy future coming
up so he said yeah these things these
vehicles they're not of this
world now check this
out you are alleging that the US
government has been concealing the
existence on this planet of alien
life I would couch it as non-human
intelligence you know nhi like we like
to say in our language why do you say
that why do you say nhi I don't want to
necessarily denote origin I don't think
we have all the data to say oh they're
coming from a certain a certain location
and I and I I couch it as somebody who
studied physics where maybe they're
coming from a different physical
Dimension as described in quantum
mechanics we know there's extra
Dimensions due to high uh high energy
particle collisions Etc and there's a
theoretical framework to explain that
yeah just let me cut to the quick though
you're saying there is an intelligent
species engaging with this planet yes
that's potentially extraterrestrial yeah
I speak for everybody sitting at home
that is a shock it was to me and uh I
had a lot of sleepless nights okay so
first we got us space force under the
Trump Administration the first time
December 20
2019 then we got this covid thing happen
and in this huge document we want to
know everything you know about UFOs now
all a sudden this
whistleblower comes out the
Whistleblower on the mainstream news the
controlled mainstream
propaganda broadcast a whistleblower
saying oh yeah there's there's crafts
and they're not made by humans and uh we
talk to non-human intelligences and he's
like are they alien he's like well I
don't like to call them alien we don't
really know what they are we call them
nhi non-human intelligences because they
might be From Another Dimension
another
dimension we're talking to intelligences
that aren't human
nonhuman intelligence From Another
Dimension tell me you're talking to
Demons without telling me you're talking
to Demons that's exactly how you would
say it now check out this clip Italian
government moved it to a secure air base
in Italy for the the rest of kind of the
fascist regime until 1944 before 1945
and you know the pop the 12 back
channeled that so the Vatican was
involved yeah and told the Americans
what the Italians had and and we ended
up scooping it so let me be very clear
about this you're saying that the
Catholic Church the Vatican they know
about the existence of non-human
Intelligence on this planet
certainly I think that's very very
interesting he's like wait minute you're
telling me that the Catholic Church
knows about these aliens and he's like
certainly
okay this is getting crazy if you
understand prophecy uh the Catholic
church plays a huge role in the Beast
system and so I just think it's really
weird because remember if these beings
are going to come and deceive the world
through lying signs and wonders and
deceptive Miracles and you know Miracle
working demons they're going to have to
look good right what better way to look
like you're on the good side than to be
hand inand with the Catholic Church the
world's larest Christian denomination
right oh my goodness it is so clear
what's happening and this stuff isn't
even fully up to date if you guys want
to be on up
toate alien all things UFO go to strange
normal on YouTube every Sunday a lot of
times I'm on there probably 50% of the
times I'm on the show with Brad and
we're talking about what's the newest
the newest info on what's going on in
the the UFO world this thing isn't going
going
away so I want to say thank you again
$1,625 we are well over halfway thank
you guys so much this book is going to
become a reality I see people saying
thank you for putting this type of book
out I think it's the first of its kind
I've never seen a book out there that
says aliens aren't your friends and that
we should test these Spirits they're
actually saying the opposite aliens and
monsters are your friends and dragons
are your pets and this is what the
mainstream media propaganda is always
pushing out since Sesame Street Yo Gaba
Gaba they're always monsters are your
friends this book is going to tell kids
the
truth here's another clip by this quote
unquote whistleblower we do know of at
least one agreement among humans that's
worth noting this 1971 agreement between
the US and the USSR on measures to
reduce the risk of nuclear war whether
or not you believe Dave grush this
document proves the two superpowers were
aware that UAP existed what ever they
were if you look at article three of
that treaty it talks about unidentified
objects near nuclear facilities are
interfering with Communications and that
is a treaty uh that has been used from
what I understand uh to
notify uh each other if there's a
concerning event and that's a way of
saying to the Russians hey don't shoot
at us it's not us yeah I mean that's
isn't that crazy he's saying that the
two superpowers of the world knew they
were signing documents this is
documented evidence that they knew UFOs
are real or whatever it is you
know all right this is building the case
that this was all pre-planned this is
all a big part of the New World Order
and prophecy and enslavement of humanity
it's Satan in
Disguise so are these beings from
another world or another dimension let's
look at some of the character traits
we're going to test the spirits right
now are these just beings from another
world that are our friends and we can
just embrace them and oh Welcome To
Earth and the pope said he'd baptize you
come on in accept Christ and be
baptized or are they from another
dimension like this quote unquote
whistleblower said so the Catholic
Church they actually witnessed something
called The Miracle of the sun this
happened a long time ago uh 100 years
ago at Fatima and it was the 13th of the
month it was October and it was in
1917 and it says they saw the sun
dance they saw the sun dance what shape
is the sun it is a disc now if you see
if you look up in the sky and you saw a
dancing
disc now people would say that's a UFO
but back then they didn't say it was a
UFO they said it looked like a wheel of
fire and they said it was Mary this
whole thing about Fatima said they they
saw Mary but they didn't actually see a
woman they just saw a wheel of fire that
was dancing around and it began to
perform
Miracles sound
familiar deceptive demons and Miracle
workking demons and lying signs and
wonders this happened
and they said it was brighter than the
sun it was so large so what I'm getting
at is we've been programmed to think if
we see something flying in the sky it's
a it's an alien flying a spaceship but
in
1917 when they saw it they thought
spiritual and they thought oh it's Mary
and she's doing these Miracles um right
here you can see that these spiritual
apparitions are not like what you see in
the movie like some hologram that you
can't capture on film clear CLE this
stuff can be captured on film here's the
supposed Mary which I would say is more
like Isis but she is being captured on
film which is just like what we see
today we see these things being captured
on Film on the news they're showing us
these because somebody might say how are
you saying they're spiritual when
they're capturing them on film and on
radar they are they're being captured on
film and radar and they're appearing out
of nowhere they're disappearing they're
splitting in two they're defying physics
on in all
ways but they're captured on radar but
we know that Satan and his demons can
masquerade as physical things in the
Bible when it talked about angels it
said two men in white apparel asked what
are you gazing at they appeared as men
when Abraham was approached by three men
these were two angels and Jesus coming
to him to tell him that the city of
Sodom and gomor is going to be destroyed
they ate with Abraham so they're
physical beings that can eat Abraham
could have took a selfie with them and
they would have showed up like humans so
these things can be caught on camera uh
I thought it was interesting that
whatever year this was the Vatican had a
nativity scene and they had an ancient
astronaut out there
interesting the Vatican has the world's
largest Observatory you know that so it
on the whole world whoever can see the
most into space is Vatican that
telescope is called Lucifer of all
things the Vatican is showing their true
colors they're gazing into the
sky and you know what I think God in all
his Mercy would show a sign that he's
coming and if the Vatican saw it instead
of repenting they would say we need to
fight against this because the the Bible
does say that um they say what will be
the sign of your coming and Jesus talks
about the you'll see the sign sign of
the son of man in the heavens well what
happened the first time Jesus came the
first time he came and was born in a
manger there was a sign in the heavens
and Wise Men followed it to his
birthplace so it kind of makes sense
that there might be a pattern and when
Christ comes again there's another sign
in the heavens who would be the first
ones to see it Vatican they got the
world's largest telescope maybe in God's
mercy he's giving a sign and instead of
the Vatican repent and surrendering to
Christ they get ready to war against him
it's just a
theory so what do what do the new agers
believe about these beings star people
also known as star seeds and sometimes
indigo children is a new age belief in a
fringe Theory introduced by Brad steager
in his
1976 book gods of Aquarius it argues
that certain people originated as
extraterrestrials so certain people
originated as extraterrestrial
and arrived on Earth through birth or
some entered as a walk in to an existing
human
body a walk into an existing human body
okay if these beings that we are seeing
that people are being abducted by and
stuff if they physical beings that are
just traveling here on vacation from uh
a galaxy far far away how would they
walk into a human body this defies
physics on every level but Luke 11:24
has the answer and it says when the
unclean spirit is gone out of a man he
walketh through Dry places seeking rest
and finds none he say I will return into
my house once I came so if we're going
to the Bible for our truth and the
answers the only thing that can enter
into a body is an unclean spirit so I
don't believe so when the new agers are
saying oh the star people some are born
here as aliens that are born on Earth
through birth and others are walking to
an existing human body yeah that's
that's a huge red flag right there I'm
going to refresh this
page and right now it's still at 1,6 and
$25 towards the $3,000 thank you guys so
much we're over halfway I know God's
going to provide I cannot wait to get
this books in the hands of people I
heard somebody ask will the donors get a
book yes you will definitely get a book
if you need more than one you'll get
more than one um if they have to be
mailed there'll be a cost of shipping
but if you're a donor don't worry about
it all
right so check this out Roger morau have
you guys ever heard of Roger morau he
was in a demon worshiping cult for many
years and this interview was in the
early 90s and he's describing
information that was given to him by the
high priest of this satanic cult 40
years before this interview so I'm not
good at math but what's 40 years before
uh 1990 it's like the 50s so in the
1950s Roger morau was given information
by the high priest of a satanic cult
this is what he said the priest
said that as the times on this planet
gets more and more
difficult and calamities of all kinds
are striking the planet more and more
frequently demon Spirits are going
to impress people with with the the
importance of Sunday
sacredness Roger when I was a teenager
back in the 1970s I remember a song that
came out talking about the age of
Aquarius mhm and since then we've seen
the development of the new age and I
wondered if back when you were involved
in spirit worship if they talked about
new age at all oh yes there was a big
thing that was coming up one of the uh
major deceptions of the last
days and the priest told us uh he had we
talked quite a while and then he said
could I have a little bit more your time
I want to do something very fascinating
he says the grain plane the Master's
grain plane for harvesting the Nations
for for harvesting the multitudes of the
earth into his cause just before the
close of the greatek controversy between
the forces of Good and Evil so we
continued you know after we express
ourselves that we're deeply interested
to know more about the activities of
spirits and he said it's going to be
done in a unique
manner this this Grand PL is going to
take people people are going to eat the
stuff because it says Spirits demon
spirits
will declare themselves to be
inhabitants of far distant planets in
the galaxies
that are coming to warn the inhabitants
of planet Earth of the impending
destruction of the planet unless
something
seriously properly is done to avoid it
and he went on say show saying
that they will
claim to have out of body experiences
are you familiar with out of body
experiences I've read about them you
know words so person's uh there some
persons are supposed to be able to you
know uh they believe in their Immortal
soul imortal soul projection yes right
goes into different parts of the world
and sees things and come back and then
they write all about it you know I've
heard of that
so due to the fact that the millions of
the earth people believe in having
people having an immortal Soul he say it
be ready readily accepted when the
spirits will through a trans medium
converse with influential people of the
lane you see now what is a trans medium
it's a chandeler today what what is
known today as a Chandler Chandler yeah
okay uh shiry
McLean's experience of getting involved
in
spiritism and with the uh inhabitants of
was inhabitant of far dist plants in the
galaxies i t the whole thing three hours
when you were hearing the Fulfillment of
what this high priest had said 45 years
ago yeah exactly 45 years before this
clearly old video was recorded 45 years
ago the satanic high priest was telling
him that demonic spirits will pose as
visitors from far distance galaxies
they'll come during a time of much
Calamity think about that are we in a
time of much Calamity there's been
earthquakes and floods that people can't
explain and they think it's not natural
and there's pandemics and all this stuff
natural disasters Calamity and when new
age the new New Age movement is on the
rise is the New Age movement on the rise
yes I can't even see a commercial or a
kids show without seeing some Lotus pose
and someone doing some SS and all this
stuff they are pushing it so hard even
in Children's Schools they're making
them do mindful
meditation new AG is on the rise like
never before and they will speak through
influential channelers so influential
people we got influencers today they
call them that influential people who
will
Channel messages from
Aliens he he said that's going to happen
in the future I believe we're in that
time right now check this out it used to
be that Christians were the ones that
were the the weirdos standing on the
side of the road with the cardboard sign
that says the end is near right we were
mocked ridiculed for thinking that the
end was near and now it's the secular
world it's like the R have swapped the
Christian world is asleep and thinking
ah Jesus isn't coming anytime soon not
in my lifetime I'm gonna you know what
I'm G to have fun while I'm here and and
so while the church is
sleeping the secular world is kind of
waking up they're like the Doomsday
Clock reveals how close we are to Doom
it's 11 it's a 100 seconds to midnight
so the secular scientific world they're
saying we're running out of time on this
earth 100 seconds to midnight climate
clock these clocks are popping up all
over the world this happened in 2020 so
knock five years off of this clock now
these clocks are popping up that are now
I guess telling us we got two years left
H 2027 I wonder what's planned for 2027
but these clocks are popping up and
saying this is how much time we got left
because something needs to change and
that's exct exactly what Roger mono said
he said it'll happen during a time of
great Calamity and these visitors from
other worlds that are being channeled
through influencers are going to say
your world needs to a big change if you
don't do what we tell you to do and keep
Sunday sacred and change all your
resources your electricity all this
stuff you're not going to survive we're
in that time I mean literally like who's
Trump's right-hand man
Tesla Tesla energy is a whole different
form of energy that's going to get rid
of fossil fuels and all that stuff right
we're going to have H AI robots in our
home and microchips in our brain
neurolink like come on if we were ever
in the end times it's
now listen to what these people who are
channeling these beings are saying this
guy um just listen to what he says he he
communicates with aliens
supposedly from what I understand they
view us as basically completely insane
when they see us worrying about things
like death they find it hilarious and
when they see us like running around
like headless chickens just to create
money just to keep ourselves alive and
they know it's all a big joke because
you can't die anyway and they say even
if we did die you can choose to come
back from the death state so what's the
message from these beings that you can't
die hm ring any bells are you thinking
Genesis right now like think about the
scenario where Eve is in the garden oh
la la la I'm walking around in the
garden and all of a sudden she sees a
reptilian
being who says you will not surely die
you can be as Gods if you die you can
just come back from the death State
that's what this guy said that the
aliens say to him that you can live
forever if you die you just come back
from the death State listen to what he
he's actually going to channel one of
them right here well I skipped that part
in one of them he he's saying all this
weird stuff and he says follow your
heart follow your excitement so even the
aliens are teaching the follow your
heart mentality that Disney's pushing
the aliser crowan do what thou Wilt so
they're pushing do what you want Break
The Rules follow your heart and you can
live forever that's the
of the garden so here's an influencer if
you don't know who this is this is Kesha
she's a very well-known musician and
when the pandemic was happening
happening she could no longer perform
concerts and so she started a podcast
and so this guy from Entertainment
Tonight was interviewing her and saying
who was your favorite guest on the show
listen to what she says what would you
say is like the coolest or biggest thing
you learned from these
conversations um with demy lado I loved
the conversation we had because she just
turned me on to like a whole new there
are a couple books she mentioned and an
app she mentioned that I immediately
downloaded and I made my family for
Christmas I was like all I want for
Christmas is us all to meditate and try
to channel extraterrestrials they're
like okay so I'm like trying to get all
my friends and family into meditating
the aliens to us so my new hobby because
of Dem L summoning that thank you he
said summoning them so here's an
influencer this is the Fulfillment of
what Roger monno was told 45 years
before that 90s interview happened in
the 40s or 50s he was told that
influencers influential people would
Channel aliens and she's on National
Television
she's a huge influence to the youth and
she's saying my favorite guest was Demi
levado another huge influencer for the
Youth and she said deado told me about
this app where I could Channel
extraterrestrials and I'm getting it for
all my family for Christmas so we can
all channel the aliens and he goes
summoning them this is like getting a
Ouija board for everybody this is let's
play with demons and let's make it look
really cool and hip here's actually part
of the interview but I want you to know
something about de lado she's a secular
artist but at this time in October of
2019 CBN News Christian Broadcast News
put out this article de lado being
baptized in Israel filled god-sized hole
in my heart I was rejoicing when I saw
this because I'm like oh praise the Lord
now an influential person musician can
be an influence for young people she
even got baptized in the Jordan River
here's her Instagram post where she
saying you know I'm an American singer I
was raised Christian I have Jewish
ancestors and she said there's something
magical about Israel and she said it was
such a spiritual thing and I uh I've
never had okay I've never felt such a
sense of spirituality or connection to
God something I've been missing for a
few years now spirituality is so
important to me to be baptized in the
Jordan River the same place Jesus was
baptized I've never felt more renewed in
my life this trip has been so important
for my well-being my heart and my soul
I'm grateful for the memories made and
the opportunity to be able to fill the
godsize hole in my heart thank you for
having me Israel so demm lado a secular
artist uh appears to get born again it
makes mainstream Christian news she
writes an article about it on
Instagram and that was October 2019 it
said well here she is remember the
pandemics happened like right after the
end of
2019 here she is right after that um
talking to Dem talking to Kesha about
channeling extraterrestrials but here's
another clip of her on Dr Phil talking
about how she had an experience with God
when she was a kid and she promised God
that if if he would make her famous she
would use her gifts to make the world a
better
place I went to church camp one time
and there was somebody who spoke in
tongues over me and I grew up Christian
so I wasn't familiar with this
experience and I remember them
prophesizing over me saying that one day
you'll be a hero to tens of thousands of
people and luckily my platform has
reached many more through social media
and through my work but um it was that
day that she said you'll be a hero to
thousands of people and she said it
would be through the art
and I knew in that moment that if I ever
were to make it as a singer I kind of
made this PCT with God that said God if
you give me the opportunity to live my
dreams I will pay you back and I will
live my life in hopes of helping others
so here she is you know back in the day
on Dr Phil saying when I was a kid I got
prophesized over that they told me I'd
be a huge star in the Arts and she said
if you make this dream come true I will
use it she made the pack to God she said
I'll use my gift to make the world a
better
place right after she got baptized in
the Jordan River this happens the
frequency of the city was just super
amazing and it was super easy to make
contact we had been meditating all week
and then it only took us 10 minutes
before we looked up and saw I like we
saw a ship what looked like a Concord
plane you know those like black ones
that look like triangles looked like
that but it had two red lights and then
at one point the ship just separated
into two different ships like I can't
explain it but you're seeing it and
you're just like cool so everyone else
saw that yeah all right so what and then
you're just kind and then there this
surreal moment of like so do we go
inside like were you okay so that's the
Kesha show she's on K's show and she's
telling her look we went out into a
field we meditated not Christian we
meditated and we saw something manifest
an orange ship that split
into defies physics defies fys for one
if these aliens are just physical beings
that live on another
world why are they going to appear just
because de lado is meditating in a field
they're suppos they're saying they're
coming from million millions of light
years away oh wait a minute somebody's
meditating in a field let's fly down
there the speed of faster than
light let's see if you're a million
light years away that means it takes I
don't even know the math is crazy on
that but because deado was meditating in
a field an alien decided to show itself
no this is not a physical being from
another world this is spiritual
deception this is demonic and so this is
liter like less than a year after she
was baptized in the Jordan River and she
was telling God years ago that she would
use her gifts for him and now she's
teaching people how to summon
demons and it gets worse because
remember what the scripture says it says
in the last days many will depart from
the faith giving heed to seducing
spirits and doctrines of demons she fell
for this she fell for the counterfit
because she wasn't in the truth she
wasn't in God's word and now she's
fallen from the faith so far that she
made a a an album of her wearing bondage
lingerie laying on a dirty mattress
that's in the shape of a cross and the
title of the album is called holy f word
and every song on there is a bash
against God how she's saying I used to
be enslaved to you but now I don't need
you and all this stuff how does that
happen how do you how are you a grown
woman being baptized in the Jordan River
you go all the way to Israel make it
public declaration in in a year you've
fallen off because of lying signs and
wonders like the Bible said she's not in
God's word and she's not seeing anything
happen in her life through prayer but
but wait a minute this works the new age
works I saw it with my own eyes I
summoned aliens this is the truth and
that's what's happening in the world
today when the church doesn't talk about
this topic doesn't talk about that this
is a deception and when
the youth gravitate towards the new age
and they start actually seeing things
manifesting things channeling words from
aliens from another world talking to
ascended masters they're going to say
you Christians don't have any power at
all look what I can do I'm talking to
beings from other
worlds this is nothing new 1 Samuel 287
said then Saul said to his servants find
me a woman who is a medium I may go to
her and inquire of her remember Roger
morau was saying in the last days that
influencers are going to be channeling
aliens this is nothing new this
channeling this medium this is in the
Bible the Bible has all the answers for
our day there's nothing in this world
that is a deception that the Bible
doesn't have some kind of answer
for do not talk to mediums what happened
to King Saul when he talked to this
medium she summoned a demon it says it
came up Elohim came up from the earth
and she screeched and and Saul perceived
that it was Samuel but if Samuel
was a True Believer he wouldn't have
been coming up out of the earth
described as Elohim looking like an old
man he would have been in a new body and
he would have been coming down from
heaven right but that's not really what
happens when you die when you die you're
dead until Christ returns and the dead
in Christ rise first and meet the Lord
in the air everyone is asleep anyone
who's been dead is dead until that
Resurrection morning when Christ returns
so this is this is why God strongly
forbids necromancy talking to the dead
because you're talking to demons and
those demons come in the form of dead
family members aliens Angels fairies all
kinds of
stuff so this is an interesting poll
because it says 6 and 10 Christian nuns
hold at least one new age belief I'm not
even sure what a Christian nun is n o NE
e but I guess they don't hold to any
specific denomination or something but
they believe in spiritual energy can be
located in physical things belief
believe in psychics believe in
reincarnation believe in astrology and
guess what they even have Christian
Ouija boards called angel board they got
Christian tarot cards called Angel cards
remember it said there must be a falling
away first before Christ returns are we
in a falling away not just the worldly
secular world is falling away but the
Christian church is falling away messing
around with Divination in the church
talking to Demons with Angel cards it's
insane thank you guys so much we are at
$2,100 right now let me refresh and make
sure it hasn't gone up praise God thank
you guys so much
$2,100 only $900 more dollars to go and
we still got some more to talk about so
ascended masters you know a lot of
people say hey why don't we just uh
let's just all agree on the same thing
we can all agree on Jesus right which
Jesus the new age Jesus the Mormon Jesus
you know because even the new agers
believe in Jesus you could talk to a new
Ager and say you need to believe Jesus
and they say oh I do I talk to him every
night him and Michael the Archangel and
Gabriel and Mary and Buddha see they
call them ascended masters but Satan has
a a different disguise for everyone he
can appear as an angel of Light a
serpent in the garden an alien and he's
deceiving the whole world Revelation
says that he will deceive the entire
world and that Christians will depart
from the faith giving heed to seducing
spirits and doctrines of demons because
of Miracles think about the scenario of
Eve in the garden if she was alive today
and she got approached by the news and
she said yeah one day I was in the
garden and I was walking along and this
talking serpent said something to me a
reptilian creature said that I I was
like God and that I could have all
knowledge and all this stuff people say
oh you had an Alien
Encounter but no Satan's up to his old
tricks Satan is doing the same thing
since the Garden of Eden this is nothing
new but yet the world is shocked what is
it what it could it be we need to know
the truth the truth will set you free
it's in the Bible and we can only not be
deceived if we know the truth we have to
get in God's word we have to study it we
have to study prophecy because the Bible
has the answers but most people don't
know that
Alistair
Crowley the wickedest man alive
self-professed wickedest man alive he
was channeling a being he was actually
having visitations by a demon he called
it a demon and it looked like this this
was the sketch he drew his name was lamb
L and in this it says uh this is a vice
they're a a documentary company it says
first of all who or what is lamb Brian
Butler says it's always been a bit of a
mystery are a bit mysterious what this
was to Crowley or what the creature was
at all you can tell by looking at at it
that it looks like a gray alien although
it preed although it precedes that wow
he says it's it's way more advanced than
than a gray
alien so so was it a self-portrait of
Crowley on the Asal plane was it an
entity that he encountered was it a
mothron
I don't know when you look into it this
is a demon being called lamb and lamb is
Tibetan for the way that's a direct
counterfeit of Christ remember false
prophets and false Christ will come in
the last days and this being was saying
I'm lamb the way those are words for
Jesus he's the true Lamb of God he's the
way the truth and the
life so let's recap here what have we
learned
that we've seen these things all through
history it's not just since the 80s or
the 90s or something like that there's
been etchings on walls there's been
medieval paintings of these things these
things have been dating back to as far
back a history as we know uh the
military has created crafts like this so
maybe sometimes what people are seeing
are military craft but that doesn't
explain everything because sometimes
they're seeing orbs that defy physics
which is the next Point these things
defy physics they make a 90° turn going
over 1,000 M an hour that would slam any
passenger in that ship against the wall
so hard that they wouldn't even survive
these things split in two they appear on
radar and disappear off radar these
things are defying physics thousands of
Catholics have had these sightings and
they perform
Miracles the new age contact and channel
them which is interesting because how
could you Channel or contact a a
physical being from another world a
cultists like Alistair Crowley see them
which why why are only the new
agers the the Catholics who are a part
of the Beast system and the new age
having encounters with them their
message is always Antichrist the message
is always you will not surely die do
what you want Follow Your Heart Right
and it's always I I've heard a lot of
these interviews with people who were
supposedly abducted the message is
always Jesus isn't who you think he is
he was an ascended Master you can
actually reach Christ Consciousness and
you can Ascend to your Mothership just
like Jesus did after his death Remember
When Jesus ascended up back to his
Mothership that's what they say so the
message is always Antichrist why would a
being from 5,000 five million light
years away travel all the way to Earth
to tell you hey Jesus isn't who you
think he is that's
satanic and these are deceiving spirits
in the last days that's what's going on
deceiving spirits in the last
days a lot of the information we get
from space and all this stuff comes from
NASA do we trust this organization this
government funded
organization so H 5377 is Hebrew NASA
and it means to lead astray to delude to
seduce beguile and
deceive and everyone loves NASA they
wear it on their t-shirts and on hats
they put deceived right across their
chest right on their forehead and the
most popular toy in 2021 when I searched
this was an
alien why such the push for space why
such the attention on us space force and
NASA why is NASA trendy doesn't even
make sense and why is an alien the most
popular toy why do they keep pushing
this I believe the stage is being set
for a great deception that's going to
take the world over like an overwhelming
surprise who should we trust more than
the ones who have been there right
they're the ones telling us aliens are
real listen to this even the astronauts
that work for NASA are telling us that
aliens are real I would not be surprised
if we are under
surveillance by alien visitors I think
they're interested in everything that
we're doing
I think just observing our progress
they're looking to see what is taking
place on this
planet I love it up here by the time she
lands in September her tally will be 666
days in
space isn't that interesting 666 days in
space while they throw their horns up
with their hands and the all you know
the 666 over the eyeball I have to take
a break at this
moment to thank you guys because we have
reached the goal and exceeded the $3,000
needed to print a thousand of this book
right here we have
$3,300 thank you guys so much you guys
are amazing because of you this resource
can be made absolutely free this large
book with full color pictures about how
to not be deceived how to learn
scripture of the full armor of God how
to fight spiritual warfare it's the only
book I know of that teaches children
spiritual warfare and that aliens are
not your friend and to go against that
whole mainstream narrative thank you
guys so much you have no idea how much
this means to us thanks to you we're
able to put this book out and if you
guys want one just hit us up it's a free
resource so
NASA the means
deceive so Tom dong he was a front man
for a band called Blink 182 if you
remember that band and somehow he got
involved with this whole UFO movement he
got CIA clearance he was so into the UFO
thing that he kept hounding the CIA I
want to know I can he said I can reach
people that you can't he's like how's
the government nobody trusts the
government nobody cares about the
government that's what they say anyway I
I know a lot of people that do trust the
government too much but he said look
people are questioning you guys
you need me you need me to reach the
youth so let me know everything you know
about UFOs and I'll spread that
propaganda to the world and let them
know the truth and he started writing
these uh graphic novels that were
supposed to be sci-fi but he was putting
all the truth quote unquote truth that
they gave him in the novels listen to
what he said on the artbell show or also
known as Coast to Coast AM listen to
this interesting conversation but it it
can do all kinds of stuff it seems to
feed off of fear it can be very dark and
threatening at times I I remember
laughing at people who would say it's
not aliens it's demons I I couldn't
laugh anymore I'm not so sure about that
there there is a very very strong link
between what people think demons are
from the Bible and other religions um
and the UFO phenomenon and what you have
is something that doesn't like man
period This Guy's not a Christian by any
means he's actually a Freemason that's
not some conspiracy theory you can watch
music videos where there's a giant
Masonic G like the logo not something
that looks like the logo the exact
Freemason logo on the drum kit he wears
the little pin lapel pin on his collar
like if you go watch the disclosed
documentary on Little Light Studios
you'll see those things I put those in
there this guy is not a Christian in any
way and he said there is a strong link
between what Bible believing Christians
called demons and Aliens he said what
you have is something that hates man
period and the host was saying I used to
laugh at people that said these this is
demonic but I don't know I can't laugh
anymore because these things feed off of
fear very interesting so we're building
a case here where is the weight of
evidence leaning right now are these
beings from another world another planet
or these interdimensional deceivers that
are going to unite the world together in
a battle against Christ that's exactly I
think's
happening so if you don't know who wovon
Bron is he was a Nazi scientist who
helped form NASA and it's right here
it's not that's not even a conspiracy
theory or anything near the end of his
life when he was sick and dying this
woman Carol Rosen was his mouthpiece and
she started giving his speeches for him
and listen to what he was telling her in
his last days he was warning her now
this is a guy who works for NASA he
helped form NASA he's shooting rockets
in the sky and hitting the firmament and
all that stuff and he's
saying deception is coming and this is
how it's going to happen there's this
step this step this
step and the end check it
out when I was a corporate manager of
fair child Industries in 1974 through
77 I met the late Dr verer Von Brown in
early 74 Von Brown's purpose in life
during the last years of his life his
Dying Years was to educate the public
and decision makers about why
space-based weapons are dumb dangerous
destabilizing too costly unnecessary
unworkable undesirable idea the strategy
that verer Von Brown taught me was that
first the Russians are going to be
considered to be the enemy in fact when
I met him in 74 they were the enemy the
identified enemy we were told that they
had killer satellites we were told that
they were coming to get us and control
us the dirty commies that whole story
first the Russians were the enemy
against whom were're going to build
space-based weapons then terrorists
would be identified and that was soon to
follow we heard a lot about
terrorism then we were going to identify
third world country crazies We Now call
them nations of concern but he said that
would be the third enemy against whom we
would be needing to build space-based
weapons and the next enemy was asteroids
now at this point he kind of chuckled
the first time he said it asteroids
against asteroids were going to build
space-based weapons so it was funny then
and the funniest one of all was against
what he called aliens extraterrestrials
that would be the final card and over
and over and over during the four years
that I knew him and was giving his
speeches for him he would bring up that
last card and remember Carol the last
card is the alien card we're going to
have to build space-based weapons
against aliens and all of it he said is
a
lie so in case you guys didn't catch all
that she said that this Nazi scientist
turn NASA
scientist rocket scientist near the end
of his life he started getting a guilty
conscience about what he was doing and
he said they're going to build
space-based weapons and he said first
they're going to the the reason for it
will be third world crazies you know
terrorists Russians and all this stuff
then they're going to say asteroids and
he chuckled because he knows there's no
such thing as an asteroid that can come
and destroy the planet destroy Earth
and then the final card the last card is
going to be aliens he said all of it is
a
lie so what I'm seeing here in the
Fulfillment of all this stuff is Roger
monno was told in the 50s 40s or 50s
that demons are going to masquerade as
visitors from other worlds all right so
demons are coming saying they're from
another
world it's going to come at a time great
calamity new age on the rise all that
stuff we're there then in December 20
202 December 20 2019 under the Trump
administrative
Administration we get a US space force
now we are pointing weapons towards the
heavens because we're we already got
land defending land and sea and air with
Army Navy Air Force but now we're
pointing weapons towards the
heavens and why why are we pointing
weapons towards the heavens people would
say isn't it just empty space out there
why are you pointing weapons out there
well that's why they have to use the
media propaganda the controlled media
broadcast propaganda to say an
asteroid's
coming oh no fear we got to pump the
fear out there and then they're like oh
wow it didn't happen over you know how
many times I've heard that
an asteroid is going to be so close to
Earth it could actually wipe us out and
didn't happen over and over it's just
programming it's propaganda and now what
are they saying UFOs are here so this is
building a legitimate reason to the
public why we need to have weapons
pointed towards the heavens but why are
there really weapons pointed towards the
heavens well the Bible has the answers
we'll find
out we're going to get there I believe
that Satan is rounding up the militaries
of the world to unite against Christ's
return fighting against Christ Earth's
humanity is going to be teaming up with
demons fighting against Christ at the
second coming but we got to get it from
scripture we'll we'll get there this is
Lou alzando he was saying that he was
diving deep into this uh Alien thing and
his higher up because he worked in the
Pentagon and the defense Department of
the the the Pentagon his higher up said
something interesting listen to it um
this is a person I respected
tremendously very very senior person he
told me he said Lou I want you to stop
stop doing
this I said okay sir I I certainly can't
but may ask why and he says well we
already know what it is now at that
moment I I honestly thought maybe it was
our own technology and I was running up
against some super uber secret sap and
you know they were telling me to stop
and I said okay sir so so it's ours and
he said no that's not what I'm saying
and he said he asked me Point Blank have
you read your Bible lately and I wasn't
quite sure where we was going with that
and I said well sir I I I I think I know
what it says what where are you going
with this and he said well then you
would know that these things are are
demonic and we should not be pursuing
them yeah and uh I I he was he wasn't
kidding he was that's exactly how how he
felt so this is a pentagon this is a do
Department of Defense
official uh saying stop looking at UFOs
because they're
demonic
correct so notice this higher up didn't
say hey it's my personal conviction that
these things could be demonic he said
stop looking at this we meaning not just
him we already know what it is he didn't
say I personally believe he said we know
what it is these things are demonic
there are people that know what's going
on in the military and there are people
that don't
know remember Satan is deceiving the
whole world so there are people that are
literally just falling for the deception
even in the higher ups but there's a
combination some know what's going on so
all this is
happening I want you to check out this
clip by Joe Jordan he's a personal
friend of mine and Brad's from strange
normal he's been on our been on strange
normal a couple
times and he works for muon and this
video I saw it back in 2011 and it
looked older then listen to what he says
he he's in muon he's
hearing alien abduction stories and
testimonies like all the time and this
is what he started catching on to when
he'd hear people's stories each one of
them said yes sir we come across cases
like this oursel where they've been able
to stop it using prayer or Jesus's name
I said excuse me how come we have never
seen this documented you're telling us
otherwise that it can't be done it can't
be
stopped first answer they usually gave
us we didn't know what to make of it I
would have been fine with that the
second answer is what puzzled me and got
me kind of angry they because it was
that one that I want you to hear for
sure they said we couldn't go there
because it might affect our credibility
in the
realm do I hear cover
up over the next 10 years I have now
worked with over
[Music]
cases of people that have been able to
stop the abduction
experience in the name and authority of
Jesus
Christ this is document
evidence this is documented evidence so
when he was going around in these
circles at muon he's at UFO conventions
basically he's hearing testimonies of
people that been abducted and all this
stuff and he was a new
Ager and he wasn't a Christian and he
started hearing stories and he'd hear
one here one there where somebody said
you know what I I was taken out of my
bed I was taken into a spaceship and
they were about to operate on me I
started praying in the name of Jesus or
singing a Himel or pray praying
scripture and I'd be thrown back in my
bed immediately and he started asking
have you guys heard about this and
they'd be like yeah we didn't really
know what to make of it and it would
hurt our credibility in the realm so
these people whether they were doing it
intentionally or not they were covering
up the truth out of fear out of from
ridicule and all that stuff they were
hiding the truth that is Jesus will set
you free the truth will set you free
when you know Christ you can escape
these supposed alien abductions there is
not a physical alien abduction happening
this is a mental game this is Satan
implanting thoughts in your mind of this
is it's it's astral projection you might
think how could Satan implant thoughts
in your mind and all this stuff but the
new agers are doing it all the time when
they go into uh meditation and they
start having conversations with ascended
masters that's not really happening
they're in their mind when they fly out
of their bodies and travel the world
that's not really happening this is a
demonic deception when you open yourself
up to that stuff whether you're messing
around with drugs messing around with
the occult you are giving Satan
permission to get in your mind and give
you these strong
delusions and God says because they had
not a love of the truth he gave them
over to those strong delusions that they
would believe the lie
we have to love the truth with all our
heart we have to spread the truth we
have to get this message to the ends of
the
Earth so this is documented
evidence he's that was 400 cases then
it's a lot more now so listen to this 1
Timothy 41 and2 it says now the spirit
expressedly says in the latter times
some will depart from the faith giving
heed to deceiving spirits and doctrines
of demons That's What's happen happening
in these
days people they're they're having
encounters they're saying this must be
real the church never told me about this
this is the truth they're falling from
the faith giving heed to seducing
Spirits we need to speak up the church
needs to start talking stop being afraid
of ridicule stop thinking this is some
fringy conspiracy theorist this is real
the military's on the news daily saying
we know they're real and so we need to
have answers as believers
Luke
2125 through 28 says and there shall be
signs in the Sun and the Moon and in the
Stars so we know that there's going to
be some kind of sign in the heavens and
upon the Earth distress of nations with
perplexity the Sea and the waves roaring
we are about to be there people are
already panicking what's going on in New
Jersey what is it what is it imagine
when they start seeing signs and the sun
and the moon and the stars men's hearts
s failing them for fear looking after
those things which are coming on the
earth for the powers of Heaven shall be
shaken something is going to be so
fearful in the heavens in the signs and
the sun and the moon and the stars we're
going to be looking up towards the
heavens and it's going to be so fearful
that men's hearts are going to fail them
for fear we're not talking about a drone
or a storm we're talking about something
crazy that man has never experienced
in this
lifetime that's going to make men drop
dead out of
fear and then this is the Hope and then
shall they see the son of man coming in
a cloud with power and great glory and
when these things begin to come to pass
then look up lift up your heads for your
Redemption draws nigh we don't have to
be afraid of what's coming we know that
there is crazy stuff up ahead and I
think 2025 is going to be the beginning
of the absolute craziness but guess what
when you start to see these things lift
your head your Redemption draws nigh
this short life is but a vapor it'll all
be worth it when we're in the Kingdom
forever do not fall for the lying signs
and wonders when Christ returns it's
going to be like lightning flashes from
the East to the West he's not going to
touch the ground we're going to be
caught up to meet the Lord in the air if
any being comes and starts doing
Miracles it's not Christ don't fall for
it the only way you could not fall for
it is to know these
verses otherwise we'd be like Christ is
here how can I deny he's doing all these
Miracles he's not going to touch the
ground we have to understand prophecy we
have to understand the
Bible Ephesians 6:12 says for we do not
wrestle against flesh and blood but
against principalities against Powers
against the rulers of the darkness of
this age or this world against spiritual
hosts of wickedness where in Heavenly
places the wickedness that's that we're
Waring against is in the Heavenly places
and they're the ones that are the rulers
of the world the rulers of the world are
the wick oh man this is just so clear to
me now that God has opened my eyes I
pray that this is making sense to you
guys
too in the book prophets and kings on
page 626 it says this transgression has
almost reached its limit
confusion fills the world we're there
and a great terror is soon to come upon
human beings the end is very near God's
people should be preparing for what is
soon to break upon the world as an
overwhelming surprise and this
preparation they should make by
diligently studying the word of God and
striving to conform their lives to its
precepts she's saying in the last days
there's a overwhelming surprise and how
we prepare get in God's word and do what
it says conform Our Lives to what it
says God's word is a sword and we have
no chance against any demonic power
without that sword we need to heed to
this
message we read this one at the
beginning but I want to read it now that
we've looked through this fearful sights
and Great Signs there shall be from
Heaven as we near the close of time
there will be a greater and still
greater external parade of heathen power
Heathen deedes will manifest their
signal power and will exhibit themselves
before the cities of the world and this
delineation has already begun to be
fulfilled now tie that in with this
Darkness Before
Dawn it says but the familiar spirits
here highlighted but the familiar
spirits as these visitants from other
worlds were called are declared by the
Bible as the spirits of devils she was
so clear these beings that say they're
from other worlds are familiar spirits
the spirits of devils then she goes on
and says but spiritualism because that's
what this is It's spiritualism in a new
disguise spiritualism which numbers its
converts by hundreds of thousands yay by
millions are going to be deceived by
this which has made its way into
scientific circles we're talking about
NASA History Channel all this
stuff it has invaded churches like we
saw with de lado and Elevation Church
podcast and all that stuff it has found
favor in legislative bodies we're seeing
that right now we're seeing that
Congressional hearings about this very
thing and even made its way into the
courts of Kings this Mammoth deception
is but a Revival in a new disguise of
the Witchcraft condemned and prohibited
of
old this is the same lie in a new
disguise a Revival of an old lie in a
new disguise she called it out perfectly
this is so powerful for us right now
this is present Truth for a time right
now check out this clip from CBN News
Christian Broadcast News they're talking
about when the war broke out between
turkey and Russia or Iran I can't
remember I think it's in here they
prayed for help a UFO came and shot
Russian tanks and they were praising God
a pillar of fire at night and Confused
Russian troops it has some asking are
ukrainians receiving Heavenly
help there's some miracle happened it
looked like some
spaceship like there was like an attack
from the spaceship
it it was like a UFO or something we've
never seen anything like it just a
brilliant flash of lightning in the sky
just taking over the whole Sky there was
some kind of a lightning was starting
shooting from the sky and and like
Sparks were going were like spreading
[Music]
everywhere a group of Russian tanks were
supposedly wiped out by a mystery UFO
attack after the family
have trapped Ukrainian soldiers prayed
to God to offer their troops some
[Music]
help and then they on the morning
they've discovered that the whole the
whole Machinery was destroyed yeah it's
it's bizarre and then the next morning
they woke up and they said all the
equipment from the Russians was
destroyed UFO attacks on Russian tanks
if only although in this case God is
real and UFOs are real as the Pentagon
has
confirmed so what they're saying is
Ukraine prayed for help during the war
and they believe that God answered that
Prayer by sending a
UFO to destroy Russian
tanks now when this video got posted on
Little Light Studios there was a divide
in in the comment section some were like
yes God is real and he answers prayer
and the others were like this was a
demonic deception now that was already a
taste
of how is the church going to react how
are Christians going to react when we
start seeing UFOs coming to help us
whether that's to get rid of pandemics
to get rid of cancer whatever it is to
get rid of climate
change when UFOs come to help are we
going to know that it's a a deception or
are we going to say look the is the
answer to our prayers we have to know
the order of Prophecy how things happen
because there's going to be a giant
false Revival it's going to look like
peace and safety the Bible says but when
they say peace and safety sudden
destruction will come upon them and
that's from
Christ check this
out the apostles as personated by these
lying Spirits are made to contradict
what they wrote wrote in the at the
dictation of the Holy Spirit when on
Earth they deny the divine origins of
the Bible so we know there's going to be
beings that come and say you know what
that Bible uh I actually wrote that I'm
Paul and that's not what I meant to say
that got changed over the years we know
that disciples are going to come this is
spiritualism Satan is going to deceive
Humanity by pretending to be disciples
that wrote the Bible and saying no
that's not what I meant they're going to
contradict the
Bible so I I looked up who are the two
witnesses according to mainstream
Christianity and this is what they say
Enoch and Elijah are seen as
possibilities for the two witnesses
because of the unique circumstances
surrounding their exit from the world
Enoch and Elijah as far as we know are
the only two individuals whom God has
taken directly to heaven so without
seeing death
so according to mainstream theology the
two witnesses could be Enoch and Elijah
we also know according to Spirit of
Prophecy
that dead disciples who are resting in
the grave they're not in heaven even
David's not in heaven the Bible says
dead disciples from the past are dead
but they're going to come because
Satan's going to deceive the world
demons are going to impersonate the
disciple
deciples possibly Enoch and
Elijah and people will
say look they're here these are the ones
that wrote the Bible and they said
that's not what it meant and this and
that and so look at look at some of the
stuff that's that people believe out
there the Bible flying machines and how
Enoch and Prophet Elijah were taken to
the heavens when you read texts written
thousands of years ago and find them
mentioning flying chariots fire smoke
and mysterious beings you can't help but
wonder whether or not the Ancients were
actually speaking about alien
visitations so look how deceptive it is
Satan could masquerade as Peter and Paul
and Enoch and Elijah and say you know
what we didn't die we were taken up in a
mother ship yeah that Chariot of fire
that took me up I've been in space all
this time and I'm I'm back and imagine
when Satan appears as Christ the
disciples watched him go up into the
clouds and vanish into the clouds now
what if a UFO comes and Jesus steps out
of the spaceship and says when you guys
watched me go up in the clouds I went to
my mother ship I'm back I'm coming to
save your Earth I'm coming to fix all
the problems Christians are going to
have to rethink everything they're going
to say wait a
minute the Bible didn't say anything
about a spaceship but maybe maybe
these archaic people just didn't know
how to write spaceship maybe that
Chariot of fire really was a spaceship
it's going to cause everyone to question
everything what we're about to face is
something like we've never experienced
before that's what Jesus says that when
when the Great Tribulation in Matthew 24
he says a time like the world has never
experienced we are the privileged ones
to get to experience that and it is a
privilege if we get to stand the test of
time and be caught up to meet the Lord
in the air that's
amazing but we know there's a great test
T coming and we need to be ready for it
this is amazing right
here fearful signs of a supernatural
character will soon be revealed in the
heavens and token of the power of
Miracle working demons the spirits of
devils will go forth to the kings of the
earth now listen to this Miracle working
demons we've just proved these quote
unquote aliens are Miracle working
demons and it goes on to say spirits of
devils or aliens will go forth to the
kings of the earth and to the whole
world and fasten them in deception and
urge them to unite with Satan in the
last struggle against the government of
Heaven by these agencies rulers and
subjects will be alike
deceived so even the the powers that be
think that these are alien visitors from
another world that's how powerful the
strong deception is but it says right
here that they're going to go to the
militaries of the World Unite them
together against the government of
Heaven which is
Christ it correlates with Revelation
1613 and 14 that says and I saw three
unclean spirits like frogs come out of
the mouth of the dragon and out of the
mouth of the Beast and out of the mouth
of the false prophet for they are the
spirits of devils working miracles which
go forth to the kings of the earth and
of the whole world to gather them to the
battle of the great day of God
Almighty we are living in that time
Heathen deities are parading themselves
over the cities of the world the
military is having Congressional
hearings saying these things are real
and we communicate with them while the
United Nations is trying to unite all of
humanity and in 1987 Reagan said that
would happen with an alien
invasion everything is falling into
place and the Bible and spirit of
Prophecy tell us directly how not to be
deceived in these last
days in evangelism page 622 it says a
power from beneath is working to bring
about the last great scenes in the drama
Satan coming as Christ that's the next
scene and working with all
deceivableness and unrighteousness in
those who are binding themselves
together in where in secret
societies it's those who are involved in
the secret societies who are behind the
scenes of all this stuff musicians
governments
NASA all of them are working as Pawns in
the big deception of this drama Satan
coming as
Christ is it any shock then that so many
musicians are pushing do what you want
to do and I'm a devil and all these
things Taylor Swift's a demon all these
rappers
are literally dressing like and
Performing like demons glamorizing the
occult and straight
Satanism bringing the world into utter
chaos so that Satan can come as Christ
he's not going to come as a
devil he's going to come and try to fix
the world people are going to fall for
this deception peace and safety he's
coming to fix the problems he's the
false
Christ check this out Maranatha says the
world is a theater the actors its
inhabitants are preparing to act their
part in the last great drama with the
great masses of mankind there is no
Unity except as men Confederate to
accomplish their selfish purpose
Confederate means secret I I've been
told Confederacy is a secret society or
a a
conspiracy God is looking on his
purposes in regard to his rebellious
subjects will be fulfilled the world has
not been given into the hands of men
though God is permitting the elements of
confusion and disorder to bear away to
Bear sway for a season a power from
beneath is working to bring about the
last great scenes of the drama Satan
coming as Christ so we just read this
and then it says the end is very near we
who we who know the truth should be
preparing for what is soon to break upon
the world as an overwhelming surprise I
believe we're right
there what she's describing is where we
are at today I hope what you've seen in
this presentation proves that to
you that we will wake up as Christians
we'll stop playing around with sin we'll
dedicate our entire lives to Christ
surrender Our Lives 100% pick up our
cross daily die to the lust of the Flesh
and live to spread the message of Truth
to the ends of the world so we can go
home and that
includes this book right here thanks to
you guys we can have this book printed
as a free resource I cannot thank you
guys enough we made our donations we
made the goal the book's going to be
printed I'm so excited let me see if we
got another slide here therefore do not
fear them for there is nothing cover
that will not be revealed that's what we
just did false christs and false
prophets signs and wonders I have told
you all things beforehand the Bible has
the answers so we do not have to be
deceived by lying signs and wonders if
you enjoyed this if you want to see more
of it and you want to watch the 35
minute well produced documentary you can
find it on Little Light Studios just
type in the YouTube search bar Little
Light Studios UFO documentary and look
for this thumbnail and you'll be able to
watch all this that was presented but in
a 35 minute documentary that's easy to
share with others so that they can have
their eyes open please share this
message far and wide we're reaching the
youth and the adults we're reaching the
world right now if you feel led to give
to this
ministry you can do so by going to
candid truth.org click on the Donate
button we also have cash app vinmo zel
we also have merch if you like cool
t-shirts that have scripture and uh
encouraging
pictures like it's be cool it's cool to
use your brain then check out our merch
on candid truth.org you can click the
button for a shop and you can buy those
shirts and we get like $5 off of each of
those and this this audio book this
video version of the book reading will
be available on our Channel I'm going to
turn it on right after this broadcast so
you guys can share this with your kids
before you even get the book you can
share the video with them and in the
book there'll be a QR code
to take you to this video so you guys
can watch it you guys are awesome thank
you so much for doing what God LED you
to give and because of you we can do
what we're doing here at can of Truth we
want to come out with more resources
more physical literature that you can
pass out if you knock on somebody's door
or meet somebody at a gas station you
can give them a small track that says
what's the truth about UFOs and aliens
what's the truth about the movie Wicked
what's the truth about the
the saying that Disney says follow your
heart we want to put these resources out
for free so that you guys can pass them
out and you don't have to share a video
but you can physically hand somebody
something and we need your help to make
that happen and we know that God will
provide he's done it here I hope that
this was just a faith booster to you
guys to see the funds happen and for
this to become a reality thank you guys
so much if you were blessed by this
please give it a thumbs up click that
free and simple way to support this
ministry click that thumbs up it really
helps this video get out into the
algorithm so that others can know the
truth about what's coming if you're new
to this Channel please click subscribe
we come up with videos like this all the
time we're always looking at uh pop
culture through the lens of the Bible
and breaking down the pagan origins of
this and that if you guys are into that
thing click subscribe click the
notification Bell so you won't miss a
video we love you guys we can't do this
without you we thank you for being here
tonight we'll see you next time on
candid truth